bonjour christopher azouni merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on dirait que
ce matin sur rtl france jeunes ont alors
tout d'abord pour bien comprendre en
quoi consiste cette loi sur les noms
occidentaux dont les quartiers est ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer comment
est ce qu'elle est appliquée au danemark
ça fait partie d'une 13 donc stratégie
qui date depuis le commencement du
siècle où nous essayons au danemark de
réduire les problèmes de ghetto c'est à
dire les problèmes de crimes de chômage
de non respect des droits des femmes
mais d'une manière avec une approche
culturelle aussi en essayant d'éviter
une concentration trop forte dans les
dans les immeubles ou où les communautés
locales ont le droit de de donner des
des logements aux au danois ou aux
étrangers et malheureusement depuis
plusieurs décennies
c'est quartier se sont sont sont devenus
des ghettos et nous avons essayé
beaucoup de deux d'initiatives
différentes sans grand effet mais le
gouvernement précédent qui était un
gouvernement de centre droite a décidé
de mettre une une d'un toit sur le 2 le
nombres de d'étrangers non occidentaux
dans ces quartiers est de détruire un
nombre de bâtiments pour changer la la
culture et la démographie de ces
quartiers et maintenant le nouvel
nouveau gouvernement qui est un
gouvernement social démocrate continue
la stratégie et est ce que cette loi
elle est efficace contre la
ghettoïsation finalement nous ne le
savons pas encore
puisque les initiatives du gouvernement
précédent viennent tout juste de
commencer et nous avons vu une
démolition de certains certains
appartements
nous avons vu aussi une un grand nombre
d'initiatives pour diminuer le nombre de
chômeurs est une lutte contre le crime
dans ces ghettos mais nous ne voyons pas
encore les résultats donc c'est très
difficile de conclure en ce moment ce
qui est nouveau avec les initiatives du
nouveau gouvernement
c'est que les initiatives auront lieu
non seulement dans les bâtiments qui
appartiennent aux sociétés de logements
sociaux mais aussi dans le reste des
villes où par exemple ce sont des privés
auxquels appartiennent les appartements
comment ça se passe le gouvernement qui
veut donc réduire de 50 à 30 % 7
cette limitation des non occidentaux
dans les quartiers que fait que fait le
danemark justement pour reloger ces
personnes j'imagine qu'elles sont
qu'elles sont du coup relocaliser
ailleurs ou oui dans d'autres surtout
dans d'autres quartiers avec des
bâtiments appartenant aux sociétés de
logements sociaux
mais c'est vrai c'est c'est très
difficile parce qu'on ne peut pas avec
un coup de magie et fut créé de nouveaux
logements pour pour ces gens donc ça
sera une stratégie qui s'appliquera
pendant beaucoup d'années avant d'avoir
un effet alors nous en france on a la
loi sur le séparatisme quel regard vous
portez depuis le danemark sur sur cette
loi
je ne connais pas en détail la loi mais
au danois au danemark nous avons aussi
des initiatives contre l'extrémisme et
des initiatives qui visent à éviter un
islamisme extrémiste
ces initiatives sa clique surtout dans
les écoles et envers les milieux où
savons où il y à un grand nombre de
radicaliser mais nous essayons au
danemark de distinguer entre les
attitudes et les actes c'est à dire que
ces permis d'être d'être très religieux
s'est permis au cid bien sûr d'avoir des
attitudes qui ne sont pas démocratiques
mais ce sont les actes envers lesquels
nous nous essayons d'appliquer les
mesures
le danemark qui prend modèle sur la
suède qui elle a une politique très
ouverte 1 / sur l'immigration justement
vous prenez le contre-pied de ce qui se
fait en semaine
oui et nous avons de meilleurs résultats
qu'en suède
si nous comparons la suède et le
danemark qui sont des pays scandinaves
les deux le danemark a fermé davantage
ses frontières aux étrangers le
regroupement familial s'est fait plus
difficile pour les époux qui ont moins
de vingt quatre heures en tout cas même
et les étangs qui viennent pour
travailler ou pour étudier sont très
bienvenues et et aussi les et les
étrangers qui viennent du moyen-orient
ce qui est important pour nous c'est
qu'on participe à la société danoise ou
à la tribu danoise si on veut parce que
le danemark est un pays très homogène et
où la grande majorité de danois désir
le le pays reste est homogène
merci beaucoup christopher heard rooney
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france je le rappelle nous est
éditorialiste et ancien conseiller du
ministère des finances d'amour